[Music]
president Trump is slamming longtime
Hillary Clinton aide uma Abidine after
the State Department on Friday released
hundreds of work-related emails from
Abba Dean's account they were found on
her estranged husband Anthony Weiner
he's the guy in jail his personal laptop
Judicial Watch the organization that
sued the State Department to get these
emails is reporting that five of the
documents released to the public of Marc
classified oh I thought they were about
yoga and a you know wedding in a funeral
here was reaction the president of
Judicial Watch tom Fitton and Florida
Attorney General Pam Bondi Tom why does
it take so long to get these you filed
for this in what 2015 yeah well it's the
deep state the FBI found these records
back in October of last year and it's 14
months later and they finally turn them
over to us a little under 700 or 800
emails and they show that confidential
information classified information was
on the laptop of Anthony Weiner to say
that I think is going to really
infuriate a lot of Americans especially
those who have security clearances and
they're asking what the president is
asking why wasn't there a serious
criminal investigation or prosecution of
Yuma Abidine and Hillary Clinton these
emails wouldn't be there but for Hillary
Clinton's decision to set up the secret
email server you mama D testified last
year Shawn that it was Hillary Clinton's
idea to get to Sisseton up and running
and this is a result this this violation
of law and this risks a national
security as a result of these emails
being on of all people Anthony Weiner's
email us computer system Pam the new
laws were broken the FBI now we have the
email so we have John Solomon's report
they were shocked at the amount of
classified material that they found then
we know all the then we know the fix was
it it was rigged to quote congressman
Matt Cade the whole thing was rigged so
Sean let go let me make myself perfectly
clear this has nothing to do with
politics this has everything to do with
the security of our country when you
have the top secret security clearance
that Huma Abedin had
you know when you send those emails that
you are violating the law and there is
no objective law enforcement officer in
this country that would not charge her
based on that all right no one but if we
go if we're gonna have equal justice
under the law doesn't call me now well
we have a case of obstruction Pam for
him and Peter struck if they rigged the
entire investigation the special
investigation and they hid the evidence
and that's why Congress is calling them
in I think struck is a tremendous amount
of trouble I think Comey is going to be
in trouble I think I think in his mind
the best the best defense is a good
offense and that's what he's trying to
do but failing at it yes all right
but I think Huma Abedin has big problems
as well as she should
your reaction Tom Fionn well you know I
think the Clinton email investigation
was compromised and needs to be redone
you had the Clinton Lynch tarmac meeting
yet commis machinations you had Peter
struck who was Pro Hillary anti-donald
trump there at every major decision on
the Clinton email matter you had Andrew
McCabe whose wife had just gotten a ton
of money from Clinton's crony what else
what evidence do you need I don't know
if Clinton or Abadie should be indicted
or even prosecuted at the end how do you
know ellen 'yes but we need an honest
investigation we haven't had that yet
and jeff sessions or whoever's involved
my department needs their job and if
they don't the president should order
them to do an honest investigation we
need like six special counsels but it's
all unfolding thank you both happy New
Year to both you